thanks for the intro that was a very
nice way of saying I have research a DD
and I do all kinds of crazy stuff some
of it connected some of it less so I do
work at the intersection of AI and HCI
and what I wanted to talk a little bit
about today was where I saw that working
well and where I saw it working less
well which was more of an opportunity to
do better for you guys and for myself as
well what I want to start with is sort
of the good old days of should say 2018
but anyway would I want to start with is
the good old days of when we started
thinking about integrating AI subsystems
within different kinds of gooeys and
frameworks and so let me start with a
dumb example which is maybe you know
from 17 years ago of somebody coming in
and working on designs for word and the
engineer comes in and says this is the
HCI designer comes in and says dude like
every every word user what they really
want to do is when they make an animal
noise let me ow or whatever we really
want clipart to be added into the
display right so really a great feature
for word users you say baa you get a
sheep and it's great okay this is going
to be the AI feature that I'm going to
build in and so the the designer would
come to the AI engineer and say can you
build me a system that does this and the
AI engineer would say totally like
here's a black box and just so you know
it's special it's a magical black box
and it will do exactly what you asked
for okay so the magical black box will
do this feature for you you say meow and
it'll give you a cat and I say I'm the
HCI designer I say well you know is this
really reasonable like are you actually
going to be able to give me a very clean
API for doing this and what I mean by
that is known inputs and very well known
outputs and you get sure-sure from the
AI person I'm gonna give you this
interface where you can make sounds into
it and out will come you know a great
thing like a cat okay so this will be
awesome this will work exactly the way
you want it but says the AI engineer
look it'll work almost all the time but
you know there are certain situations
where I just want to get a little bit
more information
from you like what version of word is it
are they in a noisy room are not in a
noisy room like a little bit more detail
would would be nice so not just saying
meow but can you can you tweak a few
knobs and levers for me so that I can do
better and the designer says okay fine
I'll add a control panel into this so
it's not just gonna be as clean of an
interface anymore I'm gonna give up a
little bit of that clarity but look the
designer says the output is gonna be
clear right whatever you tell me like if
it's a cat you're gonna say cat right
well you know says the AI engineer I can
tell you that it's 60 percent a cat a 30
percent chameleon and 10 percent ill
role was that going to be good you know
and that's a little bit of clarity that
now I'm going to have to give up so now
I'm starting to get a little bit worried
as the designer am I really going to get
what I want like maybe I can take the
max value here but this wasn't exactly
what I was expecting when I was thinking
about integrating this AI system okay
fine fine I say I'm the designer the
models gonna be stable right like the
inside stuff over here in this box
that's not gonna change right like
that's going to be consistent you're not
gonna ask me anything else about
training or anything like that and the
answer of course is well you know it'd
be really nice if every once in a while
I collect a bunch of information like
training examples like maybe the person
wants personalized recommendations maybe
they have really specific differences in
the kinds of cats they want to see and
so yeah I can't really say that you
won't be required to give me more
information and so now this this
nice-looking black box is starting to
look a little bit more monstrous and so
now you have this this demand by the AI
engineer to feed the model in order for
the model to work well okay so fine so I
lose this kind of simplicity as model
stability and the last thing so the
designer comes in and says well you've
you've forced me into this terrible
situation I mean look at this thing I
started wanting this nice clean black
box and now I have this thing so at
least please please please tell me will
you be able to explain to me why you
made the decision that you made like
will you be able to tell me why it
succeeded or failed or whatever it was
and oh yes so the AI engineer
I have just the ink for that I'm going
to put and ruing inside and he's going
to hallucinate some decision trees for
you okay this is going to be the
explanation that you get about the
decisions that we make and by now if
you're the designer you're saying to
yourself what the what like do I really
want this terrible awful thing that I
thought was going to be a clean black
box with this nice interface in the Sun
I'm gonna get this guy doc - oh it
looked too young for cliffy it's so sad
nobody thinks this is funny anymore he
used to be funny all right so our nice
cute interface now has to be shaped by
the constraints of this terrible black
box which is not actually a black box so
the simplicity that one expects as a
designer is not actually manifested in
the way the thing is actually built and
maybe you're thinking of yourself well
gee that's that's 18 years ago like you
must have made some progress today like
we're looking at today and yeah it'd be
nice if you AI and AI people are on the
same page but even two weeks ago you get
exchanges like this this is from Feifei
making AI more sensitive to the full
scope of human thought is no simple task
well some snark from Jeff Bingham who
does HCI research oh my god if there was
a field that did this already and it was
well established I mean connecting
cognitive science with psychology as if
like you know the expectation that
everyone should be aware of HCI you know
everyone should be aware is is the claim
here and some people are not and maybe
that's reasonable maybe not you know
what is this thing what is this thing
that we've actually constructed that
that is useful from the AI perspective
like have we actually come up with
mechanisms to bridge those things when
you have these noisy systems so tell me
more about the solution and you you know
the AI engineer might say you've solved
this right and so let me answer in the
way an AI engineer would expect an
answer back which is 60% yes 20 30 % no
and 10% phish tahko
okay so this is this is how close we've
come to solving this problem but let me
talk about what's actually solved and
what I think still needs to be done I
think we've gotten pretty good at some
specific tactics for hiding
the problem and some specific tactics
for showing and allowing control of the
underlying AI subsystem I think we've
come up with higher-level strategies but
they're not perfect especially given the
changes that we're seeing today and the
way AI systems are constructed and so I
think we sort of kind of have a design
language to support this and by design
language what I mean is a set of
patterns that we will use over and over
and over again in defining user
interfaces okay for the use of AI
subsystems okay as well as like specific
looks and feels so what does the UI
actually look like so not just the
pattern but the actual UI and I think
we're getting there
but I think there's still a lot of gaps
and I'll come back to that towards the
end I will say that the thing that will
drive most of the solutions that I'll
talk about in a second are two
observations that have been made both by
AI people and HCI people which is this
uncertainty sucks and you got to learn
to deal with it like we are going to be
producing uncertain output from the AI
subsystems okay the other thing that you
have to learn to deal with when you're
dealing with this is fault tolerance and
this is becomes an important and
critical aspect and I think these two
things are going to drive a lot of the
solutions that I'm going to show you
things like explanation by the way fall
into specific tactics and strategies for
dealing with us and I'm not talking
about explanations for things like bias
for example which we can come back to
later so just to be clear about what I
mean about uncertainty is if you have a
cat uncertainty means I tell you it's an
American Shorthair or an American
bobtail with a different level of
confidence but what I mean by failure is
I tell you it's a fish taco or don't
give you an answer at all okay so those
are failures and then there's everything
in between
okay so there's some combination of
uncertainty and failure that may
manifest in the inclusion of the AI
subsystem so this is the the combination
separating these two things out this is
like this is how I like to think about
this as being two different things and
there's some some areas where they
overlap but not always
there's the uncertainty aspect and
the specific strategies that I'll talk
about are either hiding the uncertainty
or allowing control of the uncertainty
by showing something about it and giving
interact interactive elements the other
dimension is how we deal with failures
and again we can have the hide in the
show okay so those are different
strategies for doing this and depending
on the specific kind of AI you have the
specific interaction of that AI with the
end-user you're going to have different
points in this space so sometimes you're
going to want to show things sometimes
you're going to want to hide things but
is there a regular principle about
talking about this let me start with
this corner over here which is hiding a
lot okay this is one of the areas that
I'm actually interested in researching
and I've done a bunch of work in this
specifically around benevolent deception
so we published a paper about this in
2013 and if you want to see lots and
lots of great examples I guess I would
refer you to this paper I'm gonna pick
out a few of what I call benevolent
deceptions and how you might implement
them in the context of AI so what do I
mean by benevolent deceptions one of the
examples that I really like in this
space is this one so yoky Matsuoka who
was a professor at u-dub when I worked
for nest
I had a robotic rehabilitation army and
you would arm wrestle with this thing
okay basically if you lost motion and
due to an accident due to whatever it
would arm wrestle with this robot and it
would basically improve your strength
and the way they would measure sort of
how far you've gone is maybe by degrees
let's say so how many degrees have you
bent your arm it turns out that people
have mental blocks around how far
they're willing to go okay so I can go
more than 10 degrees but there's
something that says in my mind I really
can't I just can't I'm gonna block on
going this the beyond the 10 degrees
like there's no there's no way I'm gonna
push this to 11 so what did the system
designers do the system designers lied
the system designers said when you're
actually at 10 they've said you're at 9
degrees and the person would say well ok
I went to 10 yesterday I'm gonna push it
one more I'm gonna get back to 10 and
now they're at 11 this is an active act
of deception right the system designers
decided to implement their solution in
this way because they've valued the
person's arm motion and they believe the
person valued their arm motion more than
the truth and so there was an active
deception on the part of the system
designers and the person couldn't tell
the difference because of physiological
limitations like just noticeable
difference stuff it would not actually
be able to tell that you were that the
system was lying to you an act of
deception benevolent deception here's
another one this is one that got me
thinking about this space Michael may
know this because this is something that
we were taught in systems class at MIT
like oh three three I don't know if
you're taking it but basically we were
we were taught about this this old case
of a telephone switching system it was
called the number one ESS and the number
one ESS was this huge monstrous beast
that would basically connect phone calls
okay and you would dial in and there was
some mechanical and electronic
infrastructure that would make a
connection turned out that every once in
a while well Moe in most cases it would
connect you to the person you were
actually calling there were situations
where would connect you to the wrong
person okay and the system knew that it
was making this mistake as it was making
it okay
there was actually infrastructure in
there to detect those kinds of MIS
connections but it was really hard to do
anything about it okay one solution
might have been to hang up another
solution may have been to put on a
different dial tone a third solution may
have been to put on an operator saying
oops sorry can I connect you to the
right person what they did instead was
just let your call go through okay this
happened rarely enough and they did not
charge you for this phone call so that
you were like fine whatever maybe I
misdialed okay it was an act of
deception by the system designers that
basically made this push the problem on
to the end user okay that's a little bit
of a strange thing to think about but
they did this right and so what I
started thinking about is what's the
spectrum of these things in terms of
benevolent and malevolent in terms of
deception okay this is a little bit of a
hard line to think about and I would say
lying to save a life that's probably on
the benevolent side
most philosophical thinkers in the space
would probably agree that lying to save
a life falls into the benevolent side
there's stuff over here like shopping
cart manipulation these are what I call
dark patterns or other people call dark
patterns this is like shoving something
into your shopping cart and then you
don't know about it and when you hit
checkout you get charged for it alright
that is called a dark pattern and that's
probably on the malevolent side the
benefit to me is is very limited as the
consumer the benefits of the company is
clear then there's stuff in between like
the robotic rehabilitation the number
one ESS which both benefits potentially
the person because the interface like
sort of it's it's a smooth thing of the
the connection to the other to the other
party on the phone is smooth but it also
benefits the provider because they don't
get annoying calls saying you connected
me to the wrong person I hope you're not
charging me for this bad phone call so
in that situation both the end user and
ATT benefit from from this deception
things like placebo buttons I don't know
if you consider those malevolent or
benevolent buttons that you click to
make you feel good about clicking
something but don't actually do anything
like crosswalk signs in some places
temperature gauges you know sometimes
those are fake anyway these are examples
in the spectrum and I would say that
there's stuff that's clearly malevolent
and some stuff that's clearly benevolent
and some stuff in between that we can
argue about okay
I'm mostly going to talk about stuff on
that side when we talk about benevolent
and the guests I guess the reason the
the way I would ask you to think about
this is is who benefits from the
particular act of deception okay so why
do we think about this and why am I
thinking about this in the context of AI
and UI we talk around a deception okay
most people do not like to think about
actually deceiving the end user which I
think raises a bunch of problems we talk
about theater we talk about magic like
those are the things that we use like
the metaphors that we use when we talk
about these acts that we do that are
actually acts of deception I think
failing to treat it as actual deception
makes it hard to design these things
properly effectively and ethically okay
so my push has been in working on this
is to stop thinking about these as like
it's just theater was just magic and
actually think about it for what it is
which is a little bit of deception the
reason why deception works and I'm going
to get to specific examples of
implementing these in a second is that
there's tension between what we want the
system to do and what it actually does
so there's a bunch of situations where
there are these tensions so we've talked
about this uncertainty and failure and
those things create these tensions so
let me give you a specific example of
attention which is that when I implement
something okay I have the system image
that is the representation as it
actually is so I am the designer and the
AI engineer and whatever I'm the person
building the product we build the system
and that is the system image the
individual the person who is actually
coming in using this has a mental model
of what that system is okay and the
difference between those things is the
tension okay the way it actually is in
the way I think it is that difference is
actually a situation in which people are
often using deception so why do we do it
like what are a specific examples in
many situations we do it because the
system has uncertainty and the
uncertainty may be of a different of
many different sorts there may be some
problems with how smart the thing is how
fast it is or slow it is how reliable or
not it is and so the things people do
are as follows in some situations AI
systems are actually too certain okay
playing a game against a virtual
billiard player is not very much fun the
AI system can score perfectly every
every time right like there is no reason
one would ever lose when playing a game
like this against a virtual partner and
so the game designer said yeah this is
not really fun we're gonna build an
artificial stupidity okay we're going to
actually cheat and we're gonna make the
system's dumber than they are so that
they're actually more fun and more
pleasant that is an act of deception
okay we are dumbing down the system we
are not actually making it work as it
was implemented to work because we want
to match the expectations of the end
user which is that they're playing a
human being and not a computer
this is probably a much more familiar
example to you the progress bar and the
progress bar of course is a always not
always often a active deception because
the stuff underneath that's not running
like at the rate that that progress bar
is moving sometimes the system doesn't
actually know how long it takes
sometimes they do and they just want to
make you stick around there very various
reasons why the progress bar motion does
not actually meet the reality of how
fast the system underneath is going this
is another act of deception the third
one and people argue with me about this
a little bit but I would say this is
this is another example in this case
engineers designed a car it was an
electric car the electric car did not
make the same noise as a standard oil
based gasoline based automobile ok did
not have those engine noises and this is
a problem of course if you're backing up
and no one knows you're there and you
know this is an issue right like you
don't want to be running over people and
things like that you also want to know
that the car is running ok and you could
engineer a solution to this in a bunch
of different ways the way they decided
to do it was actually implement a
speaker that would make noises that made
it sound like it was a real car ok so
the expectation of the end-user that
they're driving a car that they're
familiar with or being unmet with the
electric engine and so the designers had
to add a little bit of glue in there to
make that fit ok the expectation of the
end user of the person driving the car
and the people around the car were
different than the way the car was
actually behaving the other tensions
that exists are often in in the design
principles that we actually teach so
this is I always feel bad when I teach
HTI classes because we tell people all
these different kinds of things about
how they should build their systems and
oftentimes there's a conflict between
these different pieces of advice so
things like oh you should fail
gracefully and oh you should not fail
silently like these are things that may
not work together so these things also
create tensions and sometimes
necessitate the use of deception
let me give you a few more examples
about specific strategies and how they
work when we choose to deceive in HCI
some of the deceptions work based on
psychological principles so things like
just noticeable difference the inability
of a human being to tell the difference
between different shades to tell the
difference between different kinds of
touch how far they've moved with their
armwrestling robot things like
aesthetics relying on things like change
blindness all these different aspects
are things that we can manipulate and in
making deceptive systems that work this
specific one that I want to mention is a
speech recognition system this is kind
of older there were two systems phone
slave and grunt it turns out that when
you're doing speech recognition this was
one that was specifically intended to
answer questions when you're talking to
a computer and know that it's a computer
and sort of have that expectation the
inflection for questions is different
than when you believe you're talking to
a human being so when I ask a question
like what's the weather today I will say
it differently to you as a human being
and then I might say it to my Alexa
which is what's the weather today all
right that that lack of inflection at
the end that that tells me that it's a
question is problematic it turns out for
the speech recognition system so what
they did was they actually
anthropomorphize the system on purpose
like they created this thing that said I
am a human being treat me like a human
being talk to me as if I was a human
being because it turned out that the AI
system could work better when it
believed or it was when when the person
who was interacting with a belief that
it was human the speech patterns changed
in a beneficial way to the AI system
that is an act of deception I would
argue because that is not the way it
works it is not a human being but
portraying itself as such got the human
being who it was interacting with to do
the right thing in terms of generating
the right answer or sorry generating the
right way of asking the question another
way that people do this this is
something that I call mental model
deceptions like manipulating metaphors
using things like sewer morphs making
them look like the physical analogs
which has become less popular but was
popular for a long time basically making
your calendar right in your Mac OS look
like a physical paper calendar we don't
do that quite as much anymore but that's
a skew more these game designers built a
game where you were interacting with
police officers okay so you were
interacting with a virtual agent that
was a police officer turns out that
people did not like did not believe this
was a police officer I mean for obvious
reasons but they sort of were unwilling
to suspend disbelief they were they were
sort of uncomfortable with with
interacting with the system it was not
fun for them so what the system
designers said was fine okay we're gonna
tell people this I am NOT a police
officer I am an actor playing a police
officer when they did that while not
believing in the world being real the
user was tricked into believing the
metal role was real it's kind of clever
right I'm not a police officer I'm an
actor playing a police officer still I'm
telling you I'm a human being of some
sort I'm an actor and because one
expects actors to not be very good in
some roles you're like yeah fine
whatever I'll believe that you're a
police officer this is an act of
deception and one of many that we found
these these worked in in our study in in
our understanding in these situations
which is that often times users were
willing to suspend disbelief so
end-users were willing to be deceived in
a way the value of the system was high
when the lie was treated as truth
whether they whether it was completely
hidden from them or whether they
understood it to be a lie and we're just
willing to go with it an example of that
of that point of understanding that it's
a line and going with it is this so you
don't know jack is a trivia game that
used to I don't know if it still exists
but people used to play this and this is
from their their manuals a paraphrase
the user will spend a few minutes trying
to identify the limits of the AI so
pushing it and then they would get bored
and go back to enjoying the game this
notion of suspending disbelief
and so maybe a reasonable question is
now that we can deceive as should we
well so can we yes should we the the
argument that we made in the paper when
we first talked about this is one should
apply the principle of veracity which is
that deception should be a last resort
okay that is appropriate in some cases
but again it should be a last resort
okay and the notion is should we try for
these reasonable alternatives and so let
me give you some of these reasonable
alternatives at the intersection of UI
and AI so just to summarize this last
bit when we choose to hide stuff okay
like let's say the AI system says here's
a bunch of different things that I think
this image is that's a I think that's a
kind of dog at the top and a soccer ball
at the bottom so this is my uncertainty
presentation and so in the act of hiding
what we're going to do is remove the
uncertainty we're going to block that
and also remove all the other choices so
I'm just going to tell you that it's
this kind of dog because that's the best
guess that I have so this is on the hide
side the show control side is basically
asking can we find a way of presenting
this information in a way that is useful
to the end user I'm going to argue that
there's three different ways of doing
this and there's probably others but
this was the easiest for me to think
about when I was when I was drafting
this there are places where you can show
and control the uncertainty and the
failure by changing the entire interface
so this is at the very high level I'll
give you examples of all of these there
are places where you're going to
dynamically change just a piece of the
interface to support uncertainty
visualization and control and there are
places where you're actually just going
to change the widget a very low level so
the entire interface some smaller chunk
of the interface and some very specific
chunk of the interface of the widget at
the highest level and they're not very
many cases of this where we change the
entire interface I would argue that
search engines sit in that area and
companies like Google have trained us
well okay we are no longer surprised
when we go and type in a query and the
entire interface looks different than
the way it looked last
it does not you know affect us in any
way when we quit click on a link and I
would ask you to try this on some of
your searches you click on a link you go
back and all the search results change
like do you even know that this is
happening the entire interface except
with that search bar at the top is being
dynamically changed even at that level
of like going off to a website and
coming back just pretty crazy but
Google's trained us and so we're fine
with it
for whatever reason but we're showing
you the uncertainty like all the things
are being changed dynamically and people
are sort of ok with it the intermediate
stuff which I would argue is is by far
the most common are things like this so
this is a very nice example erica virtue
at Facebook wrote this really nice
medium post about this talking about
designing this feature this
recommendation feature inside of
Facebook the recommendation feature was
you would say give me a recommendations
of hair salons in San Francisco and the
expectation was that a bunch of people
would give you recommendations and you
could collect it and they started
thinking about like how could we make
this experience better than the way they
started thinking about that is by using
something called entity resolution so
figuring out which thing is being
discussed in the interface like by the
person typing the thing so this person
down at the bottom is saying I really
like the Riverwoods day spa ok
Facebook would recognize the Riverwoods
day spa as being a thing a physical
thing a physical business it is in San
Francisco because we were talking about
San Francisco and so they would create
this little box down here where you
could go to their page good directions
figure out how much they cost look at
other reviews and so on okay so the
person typing that statement in didn't
actually create that link that was done
through the AI and of course entity
resolution is imperfect as all AI
technologies are and so what they said
they were going to do to deal with this
problem is break this apart and they
were going to do three different things
so if they had high confidence and what
you were typing there was only one
Riverwoods day spa anywhere anywhere
near San Francisco then we're just going
to show you this box and it's just going
to have all the details and that's it
we're done
ok if my confidence is medium like maybe
there's a bunch of different Riverwood
day spas or
I'm not sure I'm gonna give you
something like this so slight
augmentation of the top level where you
can say it's the wrong place or you know
this is the right place
so getting the feedback that control I'm
pushing that that control back to the
end-user the else was this I have no
idea just recommend a place this is a
little bit of psychological manipulation
to get people to actually give them the
information like you know getting them
to actually link to the page but
nonetheless even though they had some
estimate of what should go in here it
was too low confidence and so they made
a decision about showing that
uncertainty in a very different way so
depending on the situation they would
use very different techniques the blog
post is a much better job of talking
about the reasoning but that's the
high-level gist of that particular
decision the other place where we see
this a lot and this has been going on
for a long time our thinking about
splitting the interface between things
that are stable and things that are
highly unstable so this is an example
implemented in Emacs 2 any of you use
Emacs make me feel old okay good a few
of you what when no one raises their
hand I know I'm in trouble anyway so
Emacs this particular agent was
implemented so as you typed a bunch of
stuff it was constantly making
recommendation so there was a stable
part of the interface the stuff at the
top was stable and controlled by the end
user the stuff at the bottom was
unstable and being fed constantly by the
AI so you had some notion of like this
is particularly stable I always know
where I'm going to get this particular
piece of information and then a bunch of
uncertain failed whatever stuff was at
the bottom placed separately this is
maybe a better example a more modern
example I would say this is not as
popular to do these days but um things
like adaptive toolbars were the rage for
a little while where there was
personalized tools being added based on
my expectation as the AI designer about
what you were going to do next as well
as what you've done in the past so that
personalized toolbar was over on the
side and it was adaptive and constantly
changing but the decision was made and
this was turns out to be a reasonable is
you always have some stable stuff
and then the unstable stuff is always
over there to the side so it's localized
and controlled people know where they
can get that information it is often of
value but when it fails you can still
get to what you actually need so this is
an example of these split kinds of
interfaces where some stuff is stable on
some stuff is unstable to deal with
uncertainty and failures in the
underlying AI system at the lowest level
and we don't see much of this these days
our actual widget manipulation so
changing the look and feel of the
widgets to display uncertainty and
failure this one probably here is the
best example as it relates to this thing
basically this is Wesley Willett and
Manish and Jeff hare did this awhile ago
they thought about ways of placing
additional information like color or
visualizations on top of existing
widgets so over here you might imagine
like I give you a bunch of results back
and I can encode through color through
ranking the different options based on
my level of confidence or uncertainty
okay so we actually as a research
project that I participated and started
thinking about how to build this in to
an actual system and we built something
called data tone which was a natural
language interface that would allow you
to construct visualizations and so you
would you would ask a question you could
either do this through speech or by
typing show me metals for hockey and
skating by country okay so this was an
Olympics database we did we had a bunch
of AI subsystems working on this and
I'll talk about why that was a problem
later but each of them tried to do a
different thing the first one tried to
do speech to text the next one tried to
do part of speech tagging and in each
little step we were making more
uncertainty okay so we had this whole
collection of things that could go wrong
that was being produced by these serially placed AI subsystems what we did
is we said okay every widget in our
interface is going to have access to
that uncertainty space and we were going
to design bake in what we call uncertainty
widgets which is that each widget like
drop-down box selection box whatever it
was that we were creating was able to
show additional information by pulling
out relevant things from the uncertainty
space okay so users would have control
like they would see that there was
uncertainty and they would also have
control over the decision-making process
and they could tweak and basically
select from that list this extended
beyond just the parsing to also the
visualization generation so making
decisions about which visualization was
best whatwhat with a particular encoding
like this was done through an AI
subsystem and again the interface like
in this case it was a selection box from
two different chart types each widget
could basically make a decision about
what to show so that the user could
control the underlying uncertainty of
the of the AI subsystems so let me move
on in the last little bit and hopefully
we can have a little bit of a discussion
about this at the end so is this good
enough like are we at the point where we
have enough techniques okay as UI
designers like we've built enough of
these things that we actually can say
and we're done okay we've solved this
problem just like implement the solution
in one of these few different ways and
we have examples and they'll be great I
would argue that this is not quite that
the case okay the first challenge that
I'll bring up is this I don't think
there's actually a very good workable
solution to making these implementation
decisions so choosing between a bunch of
these different options I think is
actually very hard to think about Eric
Horvitz many years ago hears him holding
a robot came up with mixed initiative
interactions you guys talk about this do
they know what mixed initiative is how
many ok how many have heard of mixed
initiative user interfaces okay very
quickly mixed initiative UI was a way of
thinking about the interaction between a
human and an agent where the agent was
going to make a decision about
presenting some information or taking an
action based on utility okay so what is
the expected utility if I act on behalf
of my user like fill in this form for
them interpret and the scribble as a
specific
word whatever was what is the value to
the user if I did that what is the value
to the user if I get that wrong okay so
there were basically four different
points treating the utility like is this
is this a good decision like was this
what the user actually wants and how
much will it benefit them if I make this
decision how much will it harm them if I
make the wrong decision and so on so
people started thinking about this as a
model for deciding when to use a
particular AI subsystem like when to
trigger it and actually use its output
given the underlying uncertainty of the
thing it was really nice okay it was a
really nice way of thinking about the
problem because it allowed us to think
in terms of decision theoretic terms
things like utility like what's the
value and what's the cost to the
end-user if I make a certain kind of
mistake or show a certain kind of thing
it also was able to fold in things like
asking the user for input so if the
system failed in some way or it was
uncertain in a certain way we could make
a decision based on these in decision
theoretic terms should I ask a person
whether I should take this action or not
or get a little bit more information
that would sort of up my confidence in
my decision okay so what is the value of
doing it what is the value of asking a
question these things were really really
really hard to implement okay they're
really hard to think about probably part
of the reason they're not taught
everywhere the specific instances of
them like how to actually measure
utility is tricky and difficult if you
need no other example of the you know an
argument against this is that one first
presented like when when Eric first said
this would be a great thing the actual
implementation was this okay and this is
not mixed initiative user interaction
like everyone says oh this is like an
example of why this is a messed up
system it's actually not that the
underlying system is is bad it's just
not mixed initiative interaction at all
what the what the UI designers went and
did was actually very different than the
conception of the underlying conception
it was a very different implementation
because thinking about the utility and
all these other things was highly
problematic and highly difficult
so the main point I have and this is
where I think we need better research is
giving some ability to designers to go
from thinking about those decisions
theoretic things into the actual
interface so what does that look like I
think this is a really really hard
problem and I'd love to see more
research in this area all right second
challenge second challenge is this it
used to be the case that when we built
an interface maybe we'd shove in one AI
feature yeh one AI feature we can sort
of think about what happens when you
have a zillion AI features underneath
this is more and more of the case
Photoshop I'm at Adobe visiting for my
sabbatical they have a zillion different
kinds of AI subsystems that do different
kinds of things to the images that
you're looking at this particular one
came out a few months ago it was
basically a really nice technique to
figure out foreground from background
objects you would click on a button it
would find the foreground object the
robot and hide the rest of it there were
a bunch of controls for this over here
bunch of sliders that you would use to
control okay AI system number one AI
system number two Michael you don't
smile enough and your head is not big
enough to contain your brain alright
this is called the facial liquify tool
it is a feature of Photoshop you may not
be able to read the sliders over here
it's a smile upper lip lower look
whatever and if I manipulate the slider
and forehead gets a little bigger sorry
this is another AI ish feature basically
it figures out what the face is builds
anchor points and Lois I got to
embarrass you a little bit continue so
here's the thing
there are probably much more appropriate
ways to do this kind of facial
manipulation rather than using these
sliders
okay there's probably other kinds of
interfaces that are much more natural in
order to manipulate these things but you
have to think about the fact that you
have many many of these things built
into the actual product and so the
question is what trade-off am I willing
to make between the best interface for a
particular AI feature and the best
interfaces across all the different AI
features that I have in this particular
case I would argue that they've went for
consistency right like it's a bunch of
slider sitting on the side and that's a
consistent interface to the underlying
little bells and whistles of the model
and this is going to become more and
more of a problem not just within a
product but across all products so we
have to think about sort of the
ecosystem of AI subsystems not just
within our particular designed product
but also what everyone else is doing I
think an inconsistent design language in
fact not having any design language at
all about how one should interface with
AI subsystems is going to be problematic
and I don't think we're thinking about
this the next problem is is what I call
AI chaining and I mentioned this before
this was in that data tone system that
we built turns out that AI systems are
not just working in parallel or one-offs
you're actually chaining a bunch of
these together so the input of one
becomes the oh sorry the output of one
becomes the input of the other so in
this particular case speech-to-text
feeds two NLP NLP feeds to like a DB mapper
DB mapper feeds into
visualization generator okay so all
these things are being chained and
uncertainty sort of builds up and
failures and build up as it goes and
thinking about what that would look like
in the interface and I think is a hard
problem this is one way of doing it I
would love to see more challenge for
what are we explaining there's a lot of
interest right now in explaining sort of
how the AI subsystems work this is a
really nice example if you're a machine
learning person
okay I don't know if you've seen this
this is Chris Ola and a bunch of other
people at Google they have this
distilled out pub which is a website
that has really cool things for
explaining how machine learning and
natural nets and things like that work
you have a dog and this is like the
hallucinations and whatever like I'm not
gonna get into it it's really cool it's
really cool if you're an AI person I
can't imagine anyone wanting this okay
like an actual end user I don't think
this is like the right way to explain
anything I'd also argue that the number
of end users who actually want object
recognition at this kind of level that's
limited okay so I think the AI focus
right now has been a lot on things like
object recognition and I think that
actually does not have a very good basis
for use in most end-user applications
but we can get into that I think the
other extreme this is what other people
do this is a system a clinical support
system for sepsis patients this is the
explanation okay here's a bunch of
reasons why I think this patient has
sepsis and this is pretty crazy like
this is like nice and friendly this is
like pretty insane right like that's the
other way of going both these things I
would argue yay puppies and yay sepsis
which are neither which are particularly
well maybe puppies these are expert
systems where I think we're failing and
I think I'd like to see us doing more is
making a helping people make AI
decisions and explaining AI decisions
around things that people do all the
time
so figuring out your retirement
portfolio picking between a bunch of
insurance companies car making car
recommendations and so on things that
non-experts need to do how do we explain
to those people the underlying AI
suggestion I think that's hard challenge
number five is these guys hopefully I
don't need to say too much about that
the expectation like a lot of the
patterns the design patterns that we've
built so far have assumed a big display
a big screen they don't really work when
you have no screen at all or when your
screen pixels are limited so what is the
design language look like when you shift
to a lot of these devices and there's
many of them and they're all acting
differently this is going to be a
problem because again this
ecosystem of AI enabled things that are not
displaying information in the same way
the last one that I'll bring up is this
which is that I think the models are
actually changing a lot it used to be
that I would give you a model the AI
system would sit on your desktop and it
would never change and that was nice and
great because you had a lot of control
like there was some certainty about what
it was that that black box actually
represented today because we can have
these AI subsystems elsewhere and it's
easy to deploy and change them what
we're actually seeing is a lot of people
making changes to their services quickly
ok and they don't have to wait to deploy
the next version of word they can just
make the change whenever they want
thinking about what that means in terms
of the interface I don't think we're
quite there yet ok I think that's
another challenge that I'd like to see
us working on so where does this leave
us I think we've gotten better I think
we realized that AI subsystems look more
like this and are not as friendly and
we're not building these anymore which
is also good I think we've we've come up
with good tricks we have lots of great
examples and strategies and tactics and
in other words I think we have the start
of what I would call it design language
in this space and here's the butts the
butts are this I think we and the HCI
side aren't really keeping up I think
we're sort of struggling to keep up and
not not really understanding the the
nature of the the room how fast changes
happening in the space ok so this kind
of parallel AI is in the interface
things like that we're not really
thinking about that either in the
research or in development I think on
the AI side there's also lots of
problems like the AI side we on the AI
side are not really keeping up with new
developments and HCI not really thinking
about these so you can ask me about
active learning later this is like one
of my mmm key triggers in AI and I think
in both cases we're definitely not
getting head so we're definitely not
thinking 5 years ahead about what this
is going to look like and I think we
could do better there so the takeaway is
the what I will leave you with is AI is
not a simple black box uncertainty and
failure are the things that I would
focus on when thinking about these I
think that most patterns roughly fit
into the
notion of showing and controlling versus
hiding and I think that's a that's a
useful way of thinking about this again
as I said lots of good examples no
robust design language that I would say
this is what you should do over and over
and over again well I'd like to see if
more work is in this helping people
actually make decisions designers make
decisions about which AI features to
implement and how to think about them
and then dealing with the current trends
in AI architectures I think is the other
direction that I'd like to see us do
anymore in and with that I will let you
guys ask questions thank you you can
tell that's fine no one's willing to
raise their hand now for example
Expensify I was using Mechanical Turk to
classified people's Lucy absolutely
actually involving a team in the process
when you would assume it
right that that is a pattern so we
talked a little bit about not that
specific example but we talked a little
bit about like security theater this
happens like making you think that it's
doing something more sophisticated there
is a dumb example this is a it I think
it fits these machines where you go and
dump your change into them like at the
grocery store and they give you back you
know receipt or whatever those things
make a lot of noise and that noise is
unnecessary right it is this very
theatrical thing that makes you feel
good about putting your money into the
black box okay so you feel comfortable
more comfortable in using this thing
because it makes a big show of doing
this I would argue that this is a little
bit the same situation I don't think
they want to acknowledge that there are
human beings looking at receipts like
that would make me uncomfortable in
terms of privacy and whatever but
telling you and it's an AI system then
you become more comfortable I think in
that particular case I would say that
they were a little bit more malevolent
than benevolent because I think the
benefit to them was much more high like
I think they actually did not have a
very good AI solution and we're hiding
that point you mentioned you're not
giving a line for saving life you know
and how at that point you might actually
be tolerant of the namja exception and
how do we know that we're in that space
because you know let's say you know
obesity keeps growing and you know
diabetes keeps growing and all these
devices for these things are just
failing and we're trying to give like
honest feedback to people and it just
doesn't work should we start doing when
I will have this edge whenever deception
to like people who might be at least for
like
that's a hard question I would I'm
generally against lying to people in
that situation but you can reframe the
question in a slightly different way you
can ask the patient do you want to lose
weight do you want to stop smoking do
you want to your health to be better on
these particular dimensions and the next
question is do you care about how I get
you to that point so if the person says
I want to stop smoking and you know you
you the system designer do whatever you
want to to make that happen at that
point I think lying might be okay so
when you go and try and charge a
cigarette pack at the store and the eye
system says I'm gonna lie and decline
your credit card for you you know that's
a that's a that's a solution but the
person has bought into it right they've
said I want to stop smoking and so in
that case like deception might be a
little bit more appropriate it's a it's
a value system like I don't know I don't
know the answer to that and different
people will draw the line in very
different places strong experience to
maximize the effectiveness of learning
right like are people aware of this to
be care mind so with active learning so
this is this is my little my issue with
with some AI designs there's an
assumption by a lot of AI engineers that
like people are willing to sit there in
and do these labeling tasks is this
better than this is this better than
this is this better than this and the
problem is like people are sometimes
willing to do that because it improves
their situation the kind of questions
most of these AI systems ask are not
like is this very clearly different
thing you know are these two things very
clearly different okay the AI system
knows the answer to that the places
where it's confused
are these really hard borders between I
think ahead see if I have this
ah right this is this is easy to
distinguish which is clear they are be
right you can tell me which one is
easier to tell the difference this is
hard and this is the kind of thing that
active learning systems are often asking
people to do is this one different than
this is this one different this is this
one different is that that's a pain in
the butt people aren't willing to sit
and do that so I think that's where like
the engineering expectation that people
will actually give you this kind of
feedback it just doesn't hold water like
I think people get frustrated and
annoyed and there's some research
Salima Amash i my chalk mock
they've looked at this kind of problem
and have basically done different kinds
of studies to find better ways of
presenting active learning decisions so
that people are actually willing to
tolerate it so actually asking so even
though the computer knows the answer to
this I'm gonna ask you this kind of
thing because sometimes making easy
decisions is actually nice for the
interface for like for the experience
like you don't want to constantly be
challenges but challenged by these hard
borders or hard edges that are hard to
distinguish that make sense
this is the major category of AI that's
already in use inside of cases
essentially accelerators at some level
youyou gesture to this Christoph's
project on the bar but if you think
about let's say the Google will
autocomplete those or when you double
tap switching to these are all
essentially you know in that makes
initiative framework like low cost of
failure high possible benefits and it
seems like those were neither about
showing or hiding control and
uncertainty and so on it seemed like
they would trump maybe their goal is
different like how does that fit into
this framework you're trying to pitch um
I I'm not sure that they're different I
would actually say that those are
they're making a hiding decision they
they have high confidence and there's a
low cost to being wrong so there's a
bunch of different things you might type
or might want to do and I'm just gonna
pick the top three because it's fine or
just do the thing for you because it's
fine I think from the mixed initiative
framework that is a situation where the
value is high the cost of failure is low
and I'm just going to do it right so
that's a situation where just like the
AI is good enough that like it can sort
of mask out the uncertainty right but in
some in some right this is a design
decision do I want to show the top end
or do I just want to show the top one or
do I just want to do the top one and I
think that's a design decision that is I
think at all these cases like it's a
function of the actual use of this
technology like what is how is the AI
sub system being used and how good is it
right yeah because you're always right
no and I don't think like these are
these don't need to be mutually
exclusive like there's some there's some
things in between right like you can
make you can think of interfaces that
combine features of both showing and
hiding I don't I don't mean to argue
that there's exclusively one and
exclusively the other
go back so on the show/hide spectrum
where does metacognition come into play
and I asked that because it could play
into concealment and the fact that
you're driving the patterns under
service that you show look there's data
visualization of your habits but also
from from a showing perspective by doing
little essentially formative assessments
all the way this is your patterns along
the way you can have something to tweak
what they're doing I come from an
educational perspective so if you want
prevent to a bucket in education or a
learning experience
the AI is helping you to derive better
patterns or habits at the end where is
another cognition play in that is your
hide
that's a great question I don't know to
be honest I haven't thought about it
that much
did you have some some insight or
instinct around this depends on the
audience as it always does if you're
dealing with what they call
mission-driven learners which are
usually adults they really know what
they want at the end and the conceal
that's really great because they okay I
buy that yeah I mean I buy that there's
differences in pedagogy and andragogy
yeah I mean I think that's that's
reasonable so yeah I guess that's true
in all these cases you might factor in
the end user and sort of their
expectations and yes the the motivation
and incentive structures are quite
different so it's a good point I haven't
thought about it that much
well you know hope the other questions
you know Bob it's on after a friendly
way Bob
you